retour en france notre dossier du jour
est consacré aux produits bio ce n'est
plus une mode mais a priori c'est un
phénomène durable le salon marjolaine
qui se tient jusqu'à dimanche à
vincennes attire de plus en plus de
monde les consommateurs à chatte et
mangent des aliments biologiques parce
qu'ils pensent que c'est bon pour leur
santé alors ont-ils raison réponse avec
ce reportage de françoise vallée et
jean-jacques le garrec
moi personnellement je crois que c'est
meilleur pour la santé pour le goût plus
pour la facilité de préparation se sont
rendus prendre pour lang à 10,7 et mieux
les professionnels de l'alimentation du
sable à 100 c est un bon argument de
vente depuis la vache folle et l'arrivée
des organismes génétiquement modifiés
les produits biologiques sont devenus
une valeur refuge manger bio c'est
manger sain dit la pub pourtant médecins
et scientifiques restent prudents ici à
l'institut pasteur de lille des
chercheurs ont comparé des produits bio
et non bio on a fait des études qui ont
montré que les produits bio et notamment
les légumes avait une qualité
nutritionnelle qui était intéressante
mais d'ici a montré que leur
consommation permet d'avoir une
meilleure santé c'est beaucoup plus
difficile et aucune étude ne fait cela
pour les nutritionnistes manger bio
n'est pas suffisant la santé dépend
surtout de l' équilibre alimentaire au
quotidien autre comportement ça doit
être un comportement plus sain manger
moins de graisse moins de graisses
saturées ces graisses invisible dont
j'ai plus de sucres complexes dany dont
contre dans les céréales ou dans les
féculents c'est manger plus de produits
laitiers et surtout plus de fruits et
légumes une activité physique très
complète
mais pour certains consommateurs comme
ici en bretagne une agriculture plus
propres comme l'agriculture biologique
c'est aussi l'espoir de retrouver de
l'eau potable au robinet ici l'eau est
polluée par une agriculture et des
élevages intensifs
aujourd'hui tous les spécialistes ça
fait la santé de l'homme dépend aussi de
la qualité disque ses sols pollués
peuvent retentir sur la santé de l'homme
par l'intermédiaire des cultures
maraîchères
r ou des fruits qui sont consommés crus
par l'intermédiaire de la pollution de
l'eau la qualité de l'eau c'est le défi
du siècle prochain aliments bio ou non
l'enjeu est de préserver ce capital
essentiel pour notre santé notre corps
est composé à 70% d'eau